c'est le rendez-vous incontournable dé
métal et écouter
le hellfest le festival se déroule à
clisson en loire-atlantique en 2006 pour
sa première édition il attire 22 mille
curieux quel type de musique vous venez
chercher ici ce soir du métal du
rock'n'roll du son du bon fond du métal
et du rock dans une petite commune
tranquille à l'époque ça n'a pas l'air
d'effrayer les habitants a priori qu'ils
sont c'est plutôt une vie tranquille
bourgeoise il aa priori pourquoi pas il
en faut pour tous les goûts il ya des
jeunes ya des gens qui ai mis un genre
de musique
73 groupes se produisent la première
année et très vite la renommée du
festival dépasse les frontières il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus étranges
et cette année c et c est ce à dire
qu'il est vraiment un national passe le
festival s'est il ya on a discuté avec
de man 2 mais qu'ils menaient par trois
des groupes du monde entier viennent s'y
produire comme en 2010 avec ce quatuor
bien connu des fans de hard rock
kiss le groupe américain est l'une des
têtes d'affiché de ce 5e festival c'est
leur unique concert en france et il est
réservé au hellfest on va jouer ce soir
ça sera comme si c'était le seul concert
qu'on n'ait jamais à jouer c'est pour ça
qu'on va tout donner par le passé le vin
l'histoire de se bonifier avec les ans
c'est bon pour les autres on démontre
entre savoir faire à chaque fois qu'on
grimpe sur scène
deux ans plus tard en 2012 le site
s'agrandit toujours à clisson de
nouvelles scènes sont ajoutés passant de
5 à 7
c'est vrai que les deux scènes
supplémentaires nous permettent dans
tout ce qui est
dans tous les styles black metal death
metal hardcore et c'est de pouvoir
proposer des groupes d'une envergure
assez importante mais aussi les groupes
en devenir donc on a une palette un peu
plus large et donc on tente un peu plus
tous les publics en 2012 toujours ils
sont 112 milles métalleux à pousser les
portes du festival il ya des spectateurs
qui viennent de porto qui viennent
eux-mêmes
d'amérique du sud d'asie
c'est assez incroyable de voir ça mais
le ft devenu une référence
n'ayons pas peur des mots c'est devenu
une référence mondiale en 2022 après
deux éditions annulé pour cause de
qu'ovide le hellfest fait son grand
retour et ça n'aura rien à voir avec la
toute première édition en 2006 au total
les festivités durent sept jours et ses
tacles sur deux week-ends
350 groupes sont annoncés un record
parmi eux scorpions guns n'roses ou
encore metallica
[Musique]